yeah so it starts with just a shot of us
I go boom and then Jim yeah you have two
Rangers go and then yeah Rob if you can
just fall to the ground and then you
just you're doing from his boy view hmm
you can probably make sure I'll fall to
the ground I'll go like this and then
you're probably just feeling a quick
yeah I mean I say that then get on the
board you can do right boom like that
like a cross like that
oh well no Jenna Jimmy Joe that's always
what I do Julie it's always down at
cross like that's never quite into yeah
I'm the same then you can do to emotion
and then get on the ground
good idea I mean it's not like here we
have to keep join girlfriend it's a
rolling he never knew you wanted so
static on you too and then you come up
hit me yeah I follow the ground hey just
keep going
you give me a signal you like I'm just
we got a boo yeah bit and then you go
this is Michelle
okay keep it rolling it all just be like
[Applause]
yeah all right keep it to like your
calves in two days and then I have a
line I don't know but I must be like the
one line I say is the man yeah Malcolm's
the man this time that's so yeah just
this camera comes down you know who kind
of like you know so how do you like it
or what do you think and you know I
thought real scares for psychological
with brilliant illusions and creative
imagery but now I see it could just be a
guy in a costume beating the snot out of
you yeah ah you just go yeah I thought
you know I thought real scares were
psychological delusions and creative
imagery but now I see you can just be a
guy in a costume beating the snot out of
you
extruding Street that's later wait a 90
scaredy please
now maybe a little bit more dead just
like that one coming dad yeah I mean not
like more ERISA yeah there you go
just just down a little bit more yeah
there's an art and a science to beating
up Malcolm got it down and y'all go
entertainment value yeah this is it
people are terrible we're only doing it
cuz you're recording that's a human
being no that's the thing it's like all
these cows and everything they're
actually really nice people in the get
along well but then we'll be see a
camera boom I panicked I'm sorry it's
just this is what I do when the camera
goes out it's really weird are we still
on this cuz if you get pulled over at
some point I know yeah hey my son
watches you iron which is shit asshole
newsflash
good different position that's good Hey
and action
welcome to the 90s dead where kids rule
and we eat what we want good I do one we
actually go up to the camera you know
welcome to the nineties day I like
starting ok I do well you're like arms
folded on the kids are like that we're
kids rule and we want can we leave over
7 we drink what we would water that's
cool to this dream yeah extreme water
this water is loaded with extra 4i
federally mandated ok all right I
remember certain news pledge actually
okay ready and action
news flash ready and action
welcome to the 90s dad we're kids rule
and we eat what we want good on this one
I do our news / house / - then do along
you know welcome to 90s dad for kids
rule and we eat what we want all right
so get really in the camp
okay yeah ready and action
news flash and action
welcome to the navvies dead where kids
roll and we eat what we want good as
soon as you start doing what uh so just
go yeah there's no one ghost right right
into your nose
welcome to the 90s dad and then you bet
were kids rule and we eat what we want
so welcome to 95 for kids rule and we in
yeah okay yeah arms folded on kids rule
definitely alright ready and action news
flash welcome to the navvies Dead where
kids rule and we eat what we want good
well try one more problem just welcome
to the night he's dead start right there
right yeah The Artful dead then you're
gonna go right into golden egg he's dead
okay okay ready and action
wait so so you go right into welcome to
the night after okay want straight into
the camera we're kids rule and on kids
rule arms folded a we what we want and
then some sort of motion like you know
all right okay yeah
all right just trying to think of a
different position for the it does have
to be totally different as the endings
gonna make up a lot of it alright
alright ready
mmm and actually welcome to the 90s
ready thank you that's cuz Pierce just
don't understand
good um yeah yeah there you go
says this if you can't like I can move
around if you just keep your feet
planted on this one okay alright ready
ready and action that's cuz pears just
don't understand
move that hip this way in back perfect
okay yes yes you can kiss your here's
about what you got ah so just a little
closer to body yeah that regimen is
perfect yeah okay
all ready and action this cuz parents
just don't understand
and good do the shrug on just understand
that's because parents just doing the
boosting Oh ready and action
that's cuz parents just don't understand
you still did too early is he doing it
that's because parents just don't
understand how you do whatever you want
with your hands just I don't understand
this where you do the shrug okay all
right whatever you ready
that's those parents just don't
understand
good have the shrug a little higher up
so he's in there okay and actually
that's cuz parents just don't understand
good ah I'm just like shake is it yeah
it's just cuz that's cuz parents just
don't understand okay like you like
maybe like wonderboard or something like
you're like that about like 20 minutes
here away like yeah alright that's just
cuz parents just don't understand I said
just twice yeah um let's do this ours
well that's just because parents don't
understand or actually what he could do
is just like this just it's just cuz
parents don't understand I don't think
kids it I think the arms pull under the
head down like that and up like that
yeah and we could just bring them in at
a funny angle so yeah so a head down
shaky that's just because parents shrug
don't understand okay ready and action
that's because parents just don't
understand
good little bit more of a goofy smile
that's because parents just don't
understand
that's good well then I don't like that
that's because parents just don't
understand I do this yeah yeah that's
good okay and it se awesome taste it no
grog can see good um do we want them to
wait on that so I maybe flip them up on
see no I thought that was good because
that adds the motion pretty early on to
another yeah try see me take like a step
back
yeah maybe just almost like run into it
you know it's the taste good see
but try be quiet with your shoes you
know don't want quant or anything like
that okay hey ready mm-hmm
and action it has a taste that no
grown-up can see we're good yeah sorry
ready and it has it taste it no grown-up
can see now we lost a smile oh yeah just
have your head up just a half a step
back right
ready and action it has to taste that no
grown-up can see okay yeah you'll get
pull the hat down forget that injuries
listen I've even seen it not nearly deep
enough to the extreme desert okay stupid
oh ha it's like human skin it yeah
grossest like yeah that's what I thought
is not fun
okay all right so uh two of the
mountains over there the other three
over here
sister-sister oh okay uh move I had
assumed the gooftroop pose yes budging
on that sweet frosted taste right ready
so am I already in frame here you're
going into a wool Muntean sweet for us
today
make no promises I have a concussion
all right ready baboo and action
well munching on that sweet frosted
tastes good emphasize sweet and frosted
a little bit more sweet frosted sweet
frosted taste okay all right ready and
action
well munching on that sweet frosting
tastes really good
odd move I hit this way Walmart birth
okay we'll try another one ready and
action
well much you got that sweet frosting
tastes good woman sweet taste all right
move one more step that way there you go
first
ready mm-hmm well lunching on that sweet
frosted tastes good
have you read these real fast you're
gonna read the like sugar-frosted
children of the corn flakes full of
extreme radicalness to the max and then
also yeah
hey I can't buy my way out yeah and this
is only going to be audio's you can say
right yeah here turn more and actually
like sugar-frosted children of the corn
flakes full of extreme radicalness to
the max great huh
next line there's even games on the back
like finding your way through the corn
maze hey I can't find my way out perfect
I'll go no one from the first line like
sugar-frosted children of the corn
flakes follow the stream radicalness to
the max good there's even there's even
games on the bed like finding your way
through the corn maze hey uh I can't
find my way out huh it's actually kind
of creepy
he really does sound like an ID yeah
like I could all like I could hear this
running on Cartoon Network right now
orange and white Malcolm I know right I
grew up in the 90s so I could only
witness it you know what while I got to
here - Justin your announcer voice
sugar-frosted according this part of a
complete breakfast complete breakfast if
I didn't rise that hard
I was like have a complete breakfast by
the way was enough to feed five men
right it was like we're three oranges
toast milk eggs bacon cereal okay let's
go ahead yeah more towards the mic there
you go what have you ready
sugar-frosted children of the corn licks
it's part of this complete breakfast and
a little slower you know and with kids
commercials they were a little slower
you know what we're just gonna enjoy all
right
sugar-frosted children of the corn
flakes is part of it of it is and do
that a little bit more business on sir
like you're jumping into sugar frosted
sugar
his putter this deceiver sugar frost she
is part of this complete breakfast
sugar-frosted children of the corn
flakes is part of this complete
breakfast
beautiful woman sugar-frosted children
of the corn flakes is part of this
complete breakfast
Bert voice-acting sister said you need a
balanced breakfast is that is that you
say this is a it's probably all veggies
and fruit at the moment yes it's all
organic salt prepared by us and then
like we're like uh I got these freaking
hot dog well they might work the light
the lighting was always very air no this
one's more like he's nerdy he's not
scary I know you're talking about the
bigger the bubble tape commercial yeah
well no the wedding on Lindy my fisheye
life is just going to work yeah
everywhere x 6 feet of bubblegum for you
Pam oh yeah fuck is that some of them
for the for the commercial specialist
again just every fucking one of them
it's like fuck adults no I know your
generation was fucked up
it really was children McCartney's one
to kill your parent yeah not a say these
kids we were angel generation it is yeah
like how old were you in the 90s so
you're just gonna uh right turned 13 in
1992 how about all right so relatively
in there you're you're in there
in there but it's more high school all
right go ahead on a young kid how about
some nice Brussels sprouts
it was pretty Nick Cage Brussels Frost
I could eat ass proper arson Oh final
set
how about some nice Brussels sprouts the
point you get to at the end of us eating
even though right nice bus look final is
that ready and action
how about some nice Brussels sprouts
Oh missed his mouth a bit though yeah um
and just a hit louder
okay everybody how about some nice
Brussels sprouts
you get like a really ridiculous smile
like I think this is good for you I'm a
dork and you Saturday how about some
nice Brussels sprouts
yeah just back off of all those men
Jenna looks like Gianna overweight all
right how about some next Brussels
sprouts good I'm gonna cut to an image
of the Brussels um okay and then uh was
it just that's most most awful yeah any
waste ratings I think I have you
straighten your tummy no say it that'll
be our office that's most unorthodox
yeah that's most unorthodox good looking
for the puckering of the lips I have it
come out through the womb that's that's
most unorthodox good and yeah be sure
right after docs look at again that's
most I know if the talks okay
that's most unorthodox
good um try this try it close to the
camera then go whoa that's nuts don't
know if it locks okay that's most awful
house yeah
that's most unorthodox good try one out
to go to the pool that's my fault
oh that's most unorthodox great I'll
travel does anyone have like a
handkerchief for like a nav carry
something like a Fiat just have my purse
a ho ho that's bubble-top like it's
making me nervous that's so cool
I might become cool huh we are anti cool
custom instead upon the road laughter
yeah oh wait is there anything huh what
feels wet or anything I just watch what
they do
all right he's gonna put your blood on
his face cats not just pull out of the
palm and boy we got it Rob we got it
you're gonna start in the camera again
yeah okay and action
oh that's most one over to us yeah when
was that and oh that's most often us
good go into the line a little faster oh
that's most okay
even Mike I said okay hard I don't
listen to him it wasn't to kids doesn't
hurt how wait on the back
oh you mean I kept it around wait no no
no no oh I'm being tough yes no he used
all like that yeah big Jerry curls
he did cowboy Chris
yeah like they always want the Twinkie
guy what are you implying
yeah I'm new twink more of a bear small
lottery message never yeah I used Clancy
thank you what I do
I do that to her I just click that just
one question can you think
goodnight you know turn the fucking
camera oh great just turn into the fist
did you want to record you feel my do
gonna be on yeah okay going in the
greenroom
not a club with a do you think that I
could you know claim this island for the
king of Spain Rob just discovered he can
do a Colombo accent so now he's trying
something magical in this day your every
cookie two clowns dialogue no no
oh no no no stop oh honey wait one line
good hey kids a kooky good cloud we'll
be right back after yet another message
for my favorite sponsor Isaac oh don't
listen to him this week kids he's a very
naughty boy I knew we shouldn't have
been paid in bass okay yeah yah hey kids
cookie the clown will be right back
after yet another message from our
favorite sponsor Isaac that's perfect
just a cowboy he's a clown at stake Oh
kooky the cowboy we'll be right back
after yet another message from our
favorite sponsor Isaac that's me
okay cool I'll get your fucking cowboy
kooky maybe clumpy lumpy that's good
be calm be the cow call me yeah call me
the cowboy
oh come a little closer sissy just look
so dignified a just go we need peewee Oh
peas please
is that you sorry go kill your correcto
and funky the cow
yeah copy the cowboy we'll be right back
after yet another message from our
favorite sponsor Isaac well it should be
good good I'll try to look actually yeah
copy the cowboy we'll be right back
after that blah blah is this on would it
be ready yeah clumpy the cowboy we'll be
right back after a message from our
favorite sponsor Isaac good on the
whiteness organ okay
so pretty much what happens is Isaac
appears on the screen
it's blood of the old chest fail right
my children throw me like you know God
is upon us it just cuts back to you you
just serve look shocked
don't listen to him kids yeah oh don't
listen to him this week kids it's a very
naughty boy and then like all these guns
are gonna come out and don't like start
firing at you you just oh no no one you
fall to the ground what I say I knew we
should have been paid in maize oh it
makes sense corncob pipe yeah yes
totally intentional although for this
well we'll just do this audio sucker oh
I think that so so there's this will be
doing wine then why say fire you went on
your game shot like it and this is like
a machine like three or four on that
okay so like uh I mean you know I mean
you're a cop I may be Valentine's Day
Massacre this year oh okay not the touch
of this is a weird dance I mean really
cool all the ground jizz yes sorry I can
do it and so just feel the hat flies off
it flies off yeah it does it's nice it's
nice rocky for you heck all right fuck
it was
we were viewed it got it ready yeah
remember to hold it for like you know
five seconds if that okay and action
um don't listen to him this week kids
and then he's a very naughty boy fire
good very good
beautiful beautiful system okay hold
longer level - yeah no we should have it
paid animes good no I know we should
have it paid maze made maze a little
shorter no with your beta base I knew we
should have been paid in maze good no I
knew we should have been paid in maze
good that's a salon ah let me see you
get you particular thank grown-up joke
debt paid in maze hey dummies that's
some grown-ups here oh well they pay
with my right
Oh none of us all grown up service that
was fourth disclaimer sadly that one
skipped me by haha sanding us up inside
again a good thing okay you were gonna
do that announcer and yeah so those two
announcer wise well we'll just do this
first one a few times
alright it's Isaac's extreme haunted
house see what everyone is calling the
scariest attraction this year good try
one a little bit more upbeat it's i/o
extreme ready mm-hmm
it's Isaac's extreme haunted house see
what everyone is calling the scariest
attraction this year a hint slower be a
little bit more excited on the title
it's Isaac's extreme haunted house hello
it's Isaac's extreme haunted house see
what everyone is calling the scariest
attraction this year try one of us is an
extreme extreme yeah let's go for a try
for that boys yeah okay it's Isaac's
extreme haunted house see what everyone
is calling the scariest attraction
this year good well with the next one
we'll try try on the hash boys so it's a
do you wanna start with that boys you
want our bad boys I can do the cool boys
okay I'll do that
mmm no plague to your inner fears here
we just beat the living shit out of you
most extreme houses let you walk out
with cuts and bruises here we literally
beat you to death just to listen to the
final words of these satisfied customers
good no playing to your inner fears here
we just beat the living shit out of you
most extreme houses let you walk out
with cuts and bruises hear hear we
literally beat you to death just listen
to the final words of these satisfied
customers rather than one more just
society no bling to your inner fears
here we just beat the living shit out of
you most extreme houses let you walk out
with cuts and bruises here we literally
beat you to death party complete
breakfast yeah we're probably not gonna
go with that box that's one reason we
were getting it set up now cuz I was
going to come in everything set here and
they literally just switch out the box
but now we're talking like Rob says you
might be able to do it where you just
can Photoshop a new picture in so we're
gonna see I'm still gonna leave
everything the way it is do you want to
move like the bowl out of the way so has
it clear he has you'd have to crop
around it yeah let me um I'm gonna do
one with and then one without cuz he can
say like no no I could do it so okay
we'll see ya
[Music]